the ship plugging the choke point that
funnels 30 percent of the global
seaborne trade
400 meters long and weighing more than
200 000 tons the ever given has become
an immovable barrier shutting down
egypt's sues canal
with around 10 billion dollars in trade
at stake every day
diggers
tugboats dredgers and a team of dutch
ship salvagers are working day and night
to dislodge the vessel
a hiccup like this sort of sets everyone
back everyone was already scrambling to
get back to normal and serve what has
been quite strong demand for traded
goods and
yeah no one needs another delay on on
top of everything else and it does
underline just how important and how
finely balanced the whole system is
more than 200 ships are caught in the
world's longest maritime traffic jam
some of them are now rerouting their
journey around the cape of good hope a
trip almost three times as long
the fear is that consumers will be
noticing the delays before long
biggest impact is that component parts
for electronic chemical and engineering
industries will not arrive on time
[Music]
with a clock ticking the u.s is among a
growing list of countries offering help
to re-float the ever-given
let's get some more details on this
developing story you'd like to welcome
now dr sela marcoliano he is a maritime
historian and a former merchant mariner
mr marcoyano a very warm welcome so far
attempts to re-float this massive 220
000 ton giant have been unsuccessful
besides the obvious size problem why is
this such a complicated mission
uh it's complicated because of the
position the vessel is in uh she hit and
rammed herself literally impaled herself
into asia and her stern is hung up on
africa
and she's hanging between them in the
suez canal
puts her in a very precarious position
with the weight of the vessel on its
ends you have to be extremely careful
about putting what's called longitudinal
stress but basically you don't want to
cause the middle of the vessel to sag
crack uh begin to leak or flood or
worst case catastrophically fail they
already have flooding in the forward
sections the four peak in the bow
thruster rooms they want to be careful
about minimizing further damage to the
vessel
and i understand that you believe there
are signs now that dislodging the vessel
might actually take longer than
initially thought why is that
well we saw the parent company evergreen
begin to route their vessels around
africa so that's a clear indication
that they think this may take a long
time we know the anchorages are filling
up south and north of the canal
so even if they were able to clear the
canal immediately there would still be
days of backlogs of vessels
to get out there the egyptians have
begun to dredge along the forward
section of the vessel along the port
side the north side of the vessel
but the survey company schmidt probably
would want to do a full survey of the
vessel there's there's a danger of going
too fast
and potentially endangering the vessel
they don't want the vessel to shift they
don't want it to roll and as i said
before they don't want to cause further
damage that would expand this but at the
same time the egyptians want to get this
vessel out a you know an official in
egypt today talked about the fact that
the canal will be cleared in 48 to 72
hours i think that's optimistic uh
beyond what the capabilities are showing
us right now
now the cargo industry as you know has
been trying to maximize profit in recent
years by dispatching bigger and bigger
ships with smaller and smaller crews was
this a disaster waiting to happen
well in many ways this this event was
brought on by the last closure of the
suez canal and the suez canal closed
during 1968 and you had the eight year
closure
for it uh the maritime industry had a
route around africa and they started
developing these larger vessels of what
we call economy of scale let's put more
cargo on a single vessel instead of
across several vessels
the suez canal was expanded in 2015
specifically to handle a vessel like the
ever given
and again our
economy we demand you know low-cost uh
transportation and the way to afford
that is by creating these larger and
larger vessels and the question is was
this passage of the ever given through
the canal prudent at the time if they
had concerns about high winds as the
company is saying
then the pilots on board should have
been aware of that they shouldn't have
taken the vessel into the canal the
vessel was only about five miles into
the canal at the time
very complicated stuff there dr cell
mercuriano thank you so much sir for
enlightening us
thank you